cette semaine je reçois une nouvelle
invitée elle était déjà venue vous
apprendre à vous palper les seins c'est
sophie riches c'est ali et aujourd'hui
elle vient vous montrer ses seins non
alors il viens vous parler de ses seins
oui elle viens vous parler de ses seins
[Musique]
les clichés youtube deux chroniqueuses
auteure et comédienne sophie richmond
jours bonjour alors quelle est la
particularité à toi alors moi j'ai été
opérée dessin et du coup j'ai des
grosses cicatrices
est ce que tu te souviens du jour où tu
as pris conscience que tu avais quelque
chose de différent
c'est compliqué en fait parce que ça a
commencé presque à ma naissance en fait
quelques jours après la naissance a fait
développer un an view un angelot c'est
une malformation des vaisseaux sanguins
ou lymphatique qui sont trop dilatées
ils peuvent avoir plusieurs formes et
différentes couleurs et ils sont
généralement bénins général à deux trois
mois on va hospitalisé parce que les
médecins pensaient que c'était quelque
chose de grave dans une tumeur et il se
trouve qu'en fait finalement c'était
juste un angiome et tout va bien
dans deux cas au moment de la puberté
quand ma poitrine s'est développée je
sais pas on sait pas si c'est vraiment
lié à langer ou pas mais indécent c'est
pas du tout développés comme il fallait
et il était complètement tubulaire
c'était genre 28 enfin pas à creux mais
vraiment comme une sorte de poire mais
fine à la base une courgette un peu
voilà un seul mot un seul se développer
plutôt normalement mais il y avait quand
même une sorte temps n'était pas c'était
pas 100% nickel un saint qui se
développe en forme de tube on appelle ça
un saint-hubert e ou tubulaire c'est
juste une malformation et on ne sait pas
trop pourquoi l'appareil et la prise de
conscience vraiment que c'était
différent tu l'as eu d'emblée quand avec
un patron pour ses bas d'emblée et puis
surtout à quand
quand j'ai commencé à aller à la piscine
avec l'école où là vraiment bas ça on
peut pas le cacher quoi les vêtements de
petites filles parce que j'ai une
puberté assez jeune et donc ma poitrine
et commence à pousser vers mes 8 9 ans
donc les vêtements de petites filles
qu'elles font très bien le début le
début des gouttes mais le maillot de
bain très moulant pas du tout part donc
à la vraiment j'ai réalisé que ça se
voyait que les autres le voyait donc
déjà non seulement j'étais complexée
parce que j'avais la poitrine avant tout
le monde mais en plus j'avais une
poitrine vraiment asymétrique c'est
normal d'avoir une poitrine asymétrique
mais là c'était et commentant réagi
justement quand tu te rendu compte que
j'avais cette différence mais disons que
c'est bizarre parce qu'en fait comme je
grandissais comme ça à la fois ça
faisait partie de moi est en même temps
un jeu complet que c'est beaucoup mais
en même temps je complexe et surtout est
ce que je veux complexé à ce point parce
que ma poitrine et ea était vraiment
asymétriques ou pas je sais pas mais en
tout cas le fait est que je complexe est
énormément sur mon corps
on qui l'avantagent c'est que oui parce
que j'étais aussi en plein sur un peu
beaucoup en fait l'avantagé que j'ai eu
c'est que mes parents très vite m'ont
dit si tu complexe si tu te sens pas
bien on va t'aider on va il ya eu une
opération qui existe et une fois ta
croissance sera terminé tu pourras tu
pourras te faire opérer à avoir une
poitrine
plus si les tricks c'est le choix ouais
bah du coup j'ai grandi avec cette idée
là j'ai grandi en faisant bon bah enfin
voilà clairement je me sens pas trop
bien dans mon corps je n'osais même pas
imaginer pas vraiment quand je quand je
me mets quand je vais essayer de flirter
avec avec des garçons de mon lycée
bajeux que j'imagine et l'acte sexuel je
pouvais pas imaginer retirer mon soutif
ou parce que du coup je portais en plus
des soutiens gorge très rembourré pour
cacher la différence de taille et de
forme vraiment là donc c'était pour moi
c'était pas concevable je comprends
qu'ils aient des gens qui fassent le
choix de garder leurs particularités
physiques telles quelles et moi j'ai
vraiment choisi de voilà une opération
exister pour arranger ça j'ai fait
branco aller et comment tu l'as vécu le
après opération
ça a été pour moi ça a été un
quitte à libérer non non non bah non
parce que j'étais toujours aussi
complexe et et c'est vrai que très vite
vers 15 16 ans je m'étais rendu compte
que ce n'était pas le seul complexe que
j'avais et que j'allais vraiment avoir
une relation un peu difficile avec mon
corps pour des raisons diverses de type
yoyo de type troubles du comportement
alimentaire
donc j'étais soulagé d'avoir au moins se
programme pas ce problème là régler mais
en même temps je me disais ah bon ben ya
encore sacrément du boulot pour que tu
acceptes tout le reste
cette particularité là elle a disparu
comme tu l'as dit tout à l'heure à une
autre qui est apparu les cicatrices et
cicatrices et ça aujourd'hui comment tu
le comment tu l'as vécu déjà dans un
premier temps est les cicatrices moi je
les vis très bien
alors effectivement au début elle était
vraiment très rouge et très gonflé mais
enfin on m'avait donné une espèce de
pommade en disant qu'il fallait que je
les masses régulièrement en tant que jeu
mass médecins régulièrement pour
atténuer les cicatrices pour le coup
elles sont là donc il ya ça fait une
cicatrice en forme de t sans fin donc en
gros une cicatrice autour du téton puits
vertical puis en dessous
sur chacun des saints et est donc c'est
là c'est juste plus pâle et un peu plus
gonflé que le reste je sais que je
pourrais très bien de faire retirer sa
ou atténuer sa encore plus au laser
sopic puis j'ai l'impression ouais mais
surtout bas juba
enfin j'en n'ai pas forcément envie pas
parce que j'ai peur d'avoir mal mais
plus parce que en fait un jour on m'a
dit les cicatrices ça raconte une
histoire et c'est vrai moi c'est mon
histoire même si c'est pas une histoire
rocambolesque genre j'ai pas arrêté un
bus avec médecin pour sauver une colonie
de vacances ou ce genre de choses c'est
pas un geste héroïque c'est juste j'ai
complexé sur quelque chose
j'ai été opéré pour ça et maintenant je
complète beaucoup moins mais c'est vrai
que j'aime bien mais sans comme ils sont
ils sont pas parfaits ils ont des
petites balles entre mes amis chinois
commencent à se comment ça s'est passé
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui très
vite
en fait comme entre l'opération qui a eu
lieu quand j'avais 16 ans et le début de
ma vie sexuelle et donc du moment où
j'ai montré mes seins il s'est passé
deux ans et demi et donc j'ai vraiment
eu le temps déjà les cicatrices se sont
atténuées et j'ai vraiment eu le temps
de m'habituer à ça et de les assumer de
les accepter et en fait du coup je pense
que le fait que les est à ce point
accepter ça a fait que même s'il ya eu
quelques petites réflexions dans la tête
d'eads et de mes partenaires en tout cas
je
les ai pas ressenti ou ça m'a pas blessé
ou et la plupart du temps on m'a juste
demandé enfin comment ça se fait que tu
as des cicatrices pas que c'est moche
enfin pas que ce soit moche ce genre de
choses mais enfin comment ça se fait
qu'on a c'est vrai que ça et je réponds
toujours sans problème ont parlé devant
tu n'en parlons pas ah bon tu as tant
que ça mais ça a dû m'arriver on en
parlait avant mai mais en vrai nom parce
que bah non je n'ai pas forcément envie
enfin jeu j'aurais peur de dramatiser le
truc
enfin que dans la tête de l'autre ça
fasse ce genre un genre à la dérive est
à la place des cinq ans justin voilà je
me dis j'ai tendance pas à dramatiser
mais en tout cas tout tournait un peu
négative quand tu parles de la picardie
d'où je viens
les gens ont une image devient minal
dans la tête parce que j'en rajoute
trois tonnes sans fin exprès donc j'ai
pas envie de faire ça avec mon corps en
fait c'est quoi le souci qui reste ma
formation initiale les soucis qu'ils
restent basses et que du coup comme
l'opération donc à vraiment jean-raymond
vers le saint jean comme ça comme une
escalope qu'on veut fourré avec des
petites herbes
voilà j'ai plus de sensibilité
j'en retrouve depuis quelques temps mais
sinon c'est vrai que genre me donne un
coup dans les enjeux ne sent pas ou
petits mule les singes il ya vraiment
forcer pas du tout une zone érogène
comme beaucoup plus de sensibilité
au toucher ouais du coup ça veut dire
que tu es ste tulle et considère quand
même une zone panneaux partie sexualisé
de ton corps tu les as pas vraiment
laissé de côté
je sens plus rien ils sont pas là non
non je vais les considère comme en bas
parce que même si moi je sens rien je
vois bien dans le regard de mes
partenaires que c'est le cas et enfin
comme c'est vraiment un acte est une
donnée on reçoit voilà moi je pense que
si au moins dans un premier temps pour
accepter que ce soit à malformations ou
les cicatrices après est ce que
quelqu'un t'a donné un conseil donc tu
te souviennes le meilleur conseil qu'on
a tout donné pour pour accepter ça
franchement non le nom le je sais pas
comment j'ai fait pour accepter aussi
bien le truc mais mais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on me donnait le conseil
qui a fait genre tilt ça c'est fait
hyper naturellement je crois que les
personnes que je pourrais le plus
remercier c'est vraiment mes parents qui
ont dédramatiser le truc en me disant
que je pourrais me faire opérer mais que
si je le faisais pas n'auraient pas de
soucis ça a vraiment été le truc qui a
fait que je me plaisais beaucoup moins
considéré comme un problème que ce que
j'aurais pu faire et du coup toi si tu
devais donner un conseil à des gens déjà
ivres qui nous regarde et qu'on une
asymétrie ou des cicatrices ou quelque
chose de particulier qui fait de leur
poitrine ne ressemble pas à l'image
qu'on se fait de la poitrine classique
toi si tu as un conseil à leur donner
pour
pour s'accepter ce serait quoi à ce
serait ça justement alors sachez qu'il
ya vraiment une solution pour pour
reformer la poitrine pour leur donner
une petite tête de petites pastèque ou
de petite clémentine bien comme il faut
dans mon cas c'est plutôt des
clémentines qui a vraiment une opération
qui existe j'ai pas souffert vraiment
l'opération elle s'est déroulée
parfaitement bien je devais rester
quatre jours à l'hôpital et ça se passe
tellement bien qu'au bout de deux jours
ils m'ont du bon basique quoi rentrer
chez toi mais par contre si vous si vous
sentez pas de vous faire opérer si vous
avez envie de rester comme la nature
vous a permis d'être et ben c'est pas
grave en fait chaque corps est tellement
différent moi j'ai pas fait l'opération
pour ressembler à tout le monde j'ai
fait l'opération parce que vraiment je
me sentais pas de pala faire j'avais
envie de j'avais envie d'avoir une
poitrine plus plus tradi
même si bon elle ressemble un peu
albator maintenant mais mais voilà je
dramatise là quand je dis qu'elle
rassemble albator parce que c'est le cas
c'est un bon exemple
mais voilà toutes les solutions existent
mais elles sont pas indispensables c'est
vraiment à soin de réfléchir à comment
on a envie que notre corps soit et comme
on a envie d'être et comment on sent
bien et ses drôles de choses
et de toute manière les partenaires
s'accommode de tous parce que tu es
comme ça quoi merci sochalien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]